[Música]
boa noite a todas tudo bom
meu nome é galatto é ex mas quando
voltou montada eu continuo maravilhosa
mas respondo pelo meu nome do lambert
que não é meu nome do documento não é
meu nome de batismo é o nome que eu fiz
é meu porque além de drag queen eu sou
travesti
eu sou professora eu sou mestre em
educação eu sou atriz eu sou palhaço
performers o vendedor a gente faz de
tudo um pouco né bem mas o que eu quero
falar com vocês hoje aqui eu quero falar
um pouquinho sobre histórias que a gente
não conhece sabe aquela coisa de que
toda história tem mais de um lado pois
bem a gente normalmente só conhece a
versão oficial
mas quem decide o que é oficial que é
verdadeiro que a gente entende por
verdade já foi escolhido como a história
certa que a história de quem venceu quem
tem mais dinheiro quem tem mais poder
que deu pra entender né
mas só pra ficar visualmente notável
levando à morte prática quem já leu
conhece o consome autor a sttrans outra
vez disse
pois bem e ao todo esses gêneros vocês
conhecem um calmante vai explicar o que
quer se também já morreu e não se sabe
quem não é trans né quem nasceu foi
designado ao gênero socialmente
atribuído à sua genital e assim se
identifica ao longo da vida diferente da
pessoa trânsito através dessas linhas de
gênero gênero é uma grande fã fique né é
uma grande história que contarão ea
gente opta por acreditar
é uma história convincente apesar de
falha é que nem o rpg que você escolhe
você vai jogar com o cavaleiro o qual é
o foco mago
pois bem o homem ea mulher são essas
categorias e dentro delas temos um
milhão de outras tipo o homem machista
um homem intelectual
o homem alternativo homens afeminados
homem simples 77 ea mesma coisa acontece
com mulheres muito femininas ou pouco
femininas delicadas meigas histéricas
ativas independentes ou que elas
quiserem ser com vocês né
a louca que vai falar de gente está
falando de rpg
fique isso é tudo para a gente entender
como eu vejo as relações que são jogos
né
são acordos não necessariamente formais
são tratados implícitos e tão antigos e
históricos que ganha um teor de natural
de imutabilidade de anacronismo o que
também não é verdade né que acontece
quando a gente começa a essas outras são
vix a gente pára para pensar ser homens
e mulheres sempre mudou sempre teve
outro significado em diferentes culturas
e religiões ou épocas enfim qualquer
momento do mundo as coisas não são
estáticas sabem que ela fique
é aquela história que surge depois de
uma história oficial né
são fãs que imaginam inventam e criam
outros universos dentro do universo da
ficção original
eu sempre gostei de praia fique que são
formas de ver com o outro filtro aquele
mundo aquelas personagens gente mesmo
que não oficial é tudo ficção diferença
faz é porque eu estou falando isso com
vocês o meu ponto é existem histórias
que acabam engolindo outras né então a
gente pára para pensar por exemplo até o
renascimento mulheres não podiam estar
no palco estou falando de mulheres está
pra gente deixar bem marcadinho ela não
pôde entrar no palco ou em cena ou serem
letrada sou tratados como seres humanos
né e enfim então o beijo entre romeu e
julieta
foi um beijo entre um ator e uma drag o
que não quer dizer que esse ator não era
uma pessoa transgênero ou que drag
transe é a mesma coisa isso não é o
ponto agora o que eu quero dizer que
essa história muito mal contada
a gente não consegue identificar essas
pessoas e saber como ela se entendiam ou
a identidade de gênero delas por isso
reforce é importante a gente 5 circular
outras histórias outros pontos de vista
né até então pode parecer bem específico
mas já tem outra historinha pra vocês
no renascimento especialmente na
transição da idade média o renascimento
a sociedade passaram por um processo de
mudança do hotel centrismo
antropocêntrica mesmo que na prática a
gente a mudança da anf que era oficial
as pessoas cansaram dessa história de
hoje porque deus quis que começaram aqui
a história de hal comunidade fez nessa é
nunca tem o apogeu das universidades não
é mesmo os templos da verdade absoluta
neutras científica o que é lembrando só
mais uma fonte que nessa época homens
brancos europeus doutores cunharam as
suas verdades que regeu mundo por muitas
eras após e ao mesmo tempo havia uma
produção de saberes que foi subestimada
apagada massacrada que são as mulheres
elas acabavam por criar suas próprias
formas de viver tipo superstição de voz
habitual mashhad se bem que vai curar
quem foi o espanhol gente
o médico fala outra coisa mas não quer
dizer que já não funciona né
pois bem essas mulheres especialmente as
menos desejáveis na vida social que elas
eram velhas ou viúvas ou solteiras enfim
elas acabavam sendo afastadas da vida
social e nessa margem elas criaram suas
próprias formas de cura de cuidado de
crença essas mulheres foram as chamadas
de bruxas uma mulher que mesmo sem
querer ou saber disso e desafia a
nascente imponente voz do silência
desafio patriarcado desafia as normas de
casamento monogâmico heterossexual
precisa ser votada no seu lugar então
queima entende não estou dizendo que a
gente está errada a gente não pode
acreditar na universidade nesse ponto
que eu quero dizer é que o conhecimento
não será requisitada ele é horizontal
o saber da velha senhora bruxa ele não é
menos legítimo menos importante ou menos
válido que os homens doutores mas com a
diferença que eles podem queimar uma
mulher que discorde
enquanto elas estão lutando pra existir
entende isso é assimétrico e por isso
que o teor de verdade da ciência supera
o da nossa avó que acha que se a gente
ficar vez ganhou o galo canta ou nunca
mais volta
tá mas ok parece super abstrato tudo bem
já tem uma história bem concreta para
vocês também não tem problema na escola
a gente tem um monte de coisa né
mas alguém aperta terminou com as coisas
alguém entendeu que estudar física
química e biologia era mais importante
que estudar
sei lá marcenaria gastronomia
programação de computadores corte
costura lá qualquer coisa que não está
no clube
escolares já escolheram as verdades
importantes entende que mesmo dentro
dessas disciplinas pré-estabelecidas já
escolhem também os autores as minhas
pesquisa os nomes que a gente vai
estudar na de neutro nada é isolado
entende a gente entender bem esse
exemplo porque a gente estuda a história
do brasil a partir da colonização
européia tinha gente que antes disso meu
amor
a população indígena que vem até hoje
sendo violentada dizimada e
desrespeitada passou por um processo
colonizador de genocídio de escravização
nossa de violências incontáveis e até
hoje a gente vai falar de brasil a gente
pensa em pedro álvares cabral
quer dizer pelo poder a franquia
européia engoliu áfrica indígena ea
gente só conhece essa versão mac doido
o processo colonizador além de ser
físico geográfico cultural econômico e
também com o nosso imaginário valores
nossos saberes para vocês entenderem bem
tem uma outra história aqui sobre
histórias que engolem outras que abusam
do teor de verdade que ganho lá entre o
século 18 século 19 existe uma ciência
chamada frenologia homens brancos doutor
escreveram sobre isso que validava como
verdade científica e levava um monte de
gente acreditar nessa história que só
fique falava
ela dizia que pela análise da estrutura
craniana da pessoa era possível medir ou
prever suas faculdades mentais ou seja
criamos mais robustos mais largos mas
protuberantes eram mais propensas a
serem violentos serem menos intelectuais
a serem menos civilizados
vocês sabem quem é o fenótipo de crânio
allegri tude ou seja homens brancos
usavam a ferramenta científica para
cunhar verdade que não são nada
científica são racistas
isso além de criminoso e antiético é
muito perigoso porque gera todo o
imaginário social de que a pessoa negra
menos capaz - humana seja pararam pra
pensar por exemplo que o homem branco
héteros gênero europeu ou estadunidense
burguês foi quem teve pra si o direito
de dar nome
para todas as outras pessoas foi ele que
decidiu que é negra é negra porque ela é
negra em relação ao homem a mulher é a
outra do homem
a homossexualidade é a sexualidade de
incidente a dissidente do que esse
enunciado pressupõe que o normal que a
verdade elas e hetero estranhos em sair
a visita do presidente já pararam para
pensar como essa narrativa seria
diferente se quem falar sobre isso na
época que o termo foi cunhado fosse uma
pessoa homossexual
pois bem a homossexualidade inclusive a
transversalidade também foram nomeadas
antes de heterossexualidade esse gênero
idade
sabe por quê porque primeiro a gente
nomear aberração para depois a gente vai
dar o lugar da normalidade
muito obrigada
[Música]